Bad Boys for Life is full of bullets, explosions,
and quips, but is it any good?
That depends what you're looking for.
Here are our picks for the five best -- and
five worst -- things in this long-dormant
action franchise's latest installment.
It's been more than 15 years since they last
teamed up, but Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
haven't lost a step.
By this point in their careers, both actors
have their shticks down pat, and in Bad Boys
for Life they deploy their respective charms
with military precision.
The action scenes are nice to look at, but
the banter between the two leads is where
you'll find the real fireworks.
"Hands behind your head, right now."
"I got this — I'mma penetrate this man's
soul with my heart."
When the script is clunky and the dialogue
cliched, Smith and Lawrence still make it
work.
In a different world, Smith and Lawrence would've
been a modern Bob Hope and Bing Crosby.
Since that didn't happen, we'll take whatever
we can get.
Not all Bad Boys are created equal, and Bad
Boys for Life proves it: This is Mike Lowrey's
movie.
He's the one who's targeted by the bad guys,
he's the one who has the biggest character
arc, and he's the one who drives the action
forward.
Unfortunately, that makes Martin Lawrence
more of a sidekick than an equal player.
In the first Bad Boys, Marcus is very funny,
but he's also depicted as a capable cop and
legitimate tough guy.
In Bad Boys for Life, he's little more than
comedic relief.
While Mike is out busting heads and chasing
leads, Marcus is stuck at home, engaging in
sitcom-style slapstick.
We get it, of course: Will Smith is the bigger
star.
But Bad Boys is supposed to be a partnership,
and in the series' third installment, Smith
is clearly the star of the show.
"Yo, day one, Miami Beach, son.
Little Mike Lowery got me tearing up about
this thing."
The first Bad Boys came out 25 years ago.
Will Smith is now 51.
Martin Lawrence is 54.
To pretend that they're both still young would
be ridiculous.
But Bad Boys for Life lets its actors show
their age — and it's a better movie for
it.
Lowrey and Burnett are still cop caricatures,
but they feel more lived-in than ever before,
which helps to sell the drama.
"It's probably the last year my knees will
work."
"Ha."
"Ha ha ha."
The characters' ages also let Bad Boys for
Life tackle an inconvenient truth: Bad Boys
hasn't aged particularly well.
The older movies are homophobic and slightly
racist.
Lowrey and Burnett's shoot first, ask questions
later-style of policing is a little harder
to swallow given recent conversations about
police brutality.
Bad Boys for Life deals with those issues,
at least indirectly.
It's still gleefully un-PC, with a fantastically
high body count.
Still, a little self-awareness goes a long
way.
Bad Boys for Life succeeds because of its
cast, but its script does them very few favors.
Many of Smith and Lawrence's one-liners, especially
those in the first half of the movie, feel
stale.
We've seen a cop pulled out of retirement
for "one last job" so often that it's beyond
a cliche.
Beyond some memorable villains and a couple
of plot twists, most of the story is forgettable.
The same goes for the action scenes.
After 25 years, over the top, Michael Bay-esque
explosion-fests are starting to have diminishing
returns.
The action gets the job done, but it's not
particularly exciting or interesting.
This may be one of 2020's first movies, but
in a lot of ways, it's still stuck in the
mid-90s.
Bad Boys for Life is the most personal Bad
Boys film yet.
Marcus has always been a family man, but the
one-two punch of a new grandkid and a fresh
son-in-law make him think about hanging up
his gun and badge for good.
Mike has it even worse: At the beginning of
the movie, he's gunned down in a surprise
drive-by shooting by an old rival, setting
him on the road towards vengeance.
The Bad Boys have always been fun to watch,
but in Bad Boys for Life, they're also relatable.
For the first time, it feels like we're getting
a glimpse at what’s underneath their cool,
wisecracking demeanors.
The old "One last job" cliche never works
out well for the people involved, and it's
never clear whether Mike or Marcus are going
to survive until the credits roll.
There are real consequences for the characters
in this movie.
Compared to Bad Boys II, in which the boys
just up and decide to single-handedly invade
Cuba, that's kind of a miracle.
Bad Boys for Life raises interesting questions,
and doesn't really do anything with them,
from Marcus' solemn promise to be done with
violence to Mike's newfound sense of vulnerability,
and the anger that comes with it.
Both of those concepts suggest unique stories
for the characters, but these weighty themes
generally end up either ignored, or just played
for laughs.
Lowrey's fury is simply used as an excuse
to get him involved with the investigation.
Burnett's attempts to keep from killing fuel
punchlines, not character arcs, and pay off
with Marcus picking up a machine gun and kicking
ass.
Now, this is Bad Boys.
It's supposed to be fun, not introspective.
Still, it feels like a bit of perhaps wasted
potential.
Directors Adil El Arbi and Billal Fallah are
the first people not named Michael Bay to
direct a Bad Boys movie, but don't feel bad
if you haven't heard of them: Bad Boys for
Life is their first major American film.
Arbi and Fallah capture Bay's style without
mimicking him completely.
They don't move the camera as much, and they
give some of the bigger shots more room to
breathe.
By the time the movie's over, it feels clear
that some new blood behind the camera was
exactly what the franchise needed.
So, about that plot twist...
Without giving too much away, Bad Boys for
Life's third act kicks off with a major revelation.
As it turns out, Isabel has a much more personal
reason for hunting Mike than the film initially
lets on.
Unfortunately, the big twist comes more or
less out of nowhere.
It's a secret so big that even Marcus Burnett
— Mike's best friend for over 25 years — doesn't
know about it.
That doesn't really ring true, and unfortunately,
the reveal derails Bad Boys for Life's climax
and sucks all the fun out of the room.
Even worse, it needlessly complicates Mike
Lowrey’s origin story.
Bad Boys establishes that Lowrey is a handsome,
privileged trust-fund kid who always dreamed
about being a cop.
He takes his job seriously, but he's also
entitled and not used to being told no.
It's a great, simple backstory that explains
everything the character does perfectly.
It didn't need to be any more complicated.
Bad Boys for Life isn't the sort of film that
you watch for callbacks, references, or Easter
eggs.
And yet, somehow, it's full if nods to the
previous two films.
Even better, these Easter eggs don't call
attention to themselves.
They're fun for diehard Bad Boys fans, but
series newcomers will find them funny, too.
And boy, are there a lot of 'em.
Marcus' quip that the "Bad Boys" lyrics are
hard to learn is a throwback to Bad Boys 2,
which reveals that he doesn't know the words
to his own self-appointed theme song, as is
his reference to his one good butt cheek,
after Mike shot him in the rear in the last
movie.
And then, of course, there's Michael Bay himself
as the MC at Marcus' daughter's wedding, a
cameo that's tailor-made for the film nerds
in the audience.
Even the kids at AMMO get in on the action.
When Will Smith dismisses the young task force
as a bunch of High School Musical wannabes,
it's not just a sly dig: his co-star, Vanessa
Hudgens, rose to fame as the lead of the Disney
Channel series.
Ending Bad Boys for Life on a cliffhanger
feels unnecessary.
By the end of the film, Lowrey and Burnett
have gone through complete arcs, and they're
content with their places in the world.
Dramatically, there's nowhere else for these
characters to go.
But it looks like they're forging forward
anyway; as of mid-January, a fourth movie
is already in the works, according to The
Hollywood Reporter.
Reportedly, we won't have to wait as long
to see the Boys again as we did between 1
& 2, but one wonders if it wouldn't have been
smarter to just wrap this unlikely series
up more tidily, and just go out on top.
The Bad Boys are getting older, and it really
makes you wonder what they're going to do
for the next one.
At this rate, they're gonna have to start
calling them Bad Grandpas.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.